hi guys listen I wanted to create a
video to show you what happens inside
your body in relationship to insulin
fat-burning the effects that it can
create and give you a real inside
demonstration of what it looks like so
we're gonna do some animation through
here okay let's first start out with
this one image right here which we have
the pancreas right here and the pancreas
makes certain hormones one hormone it
makes is called insulin and the location
of the pancreas is underneath the left
ribcage but it extends over to the right
a little bit and it it's triggered by
sugar okay so when you eat a
carbohydrate rich meal and the faster
that it turns into sugar like certain
things will turn the sugar fast other
things are slow that's called like a
glycemic index like celery would turn
into sugar very slowly
candy it would be very fast so as soon
as the sugar spikes in the blood and it
goes above a certain level it triggers
the pancreas to make insulin so now we
have this insulin that connects into the
cell
so insulin actually will remove the
sugar out of the blood to bring the
sugar down okay and what it does is it
feeds the cell one of the functions that
it feeds the cell so it's kind of like a
little chef that it feeds the cell it's
food okay it's fuel so you can look at
insulin also as a key that opens a door
allowing the cell to absorb glucose okay
so as glucose goes inside the cell now
we have a situation where the cell is
filled with glucose and it's being fed
now there's a signal that then we'll go
from the cell back up to the pancreas
and tell the pancreas to turn off
because it's been fed so we have this
on/off mechanism it's called a feedback
loop and all the hormones have this
feedback loop where the the hormones is
sent across a distance it does its
function and then it's once it's done it
sends a signal back letting you know the
gland note it did its job as an
acknowledgment so
can turn off if this signal is off in
any way and the pancreas will continue
to communicate and send more hormone
when you really might not need it okay
so we know number one insulin feeds to
the cell fuel
okay then it helps you store sugar
so here's insulin it comes in your takes
the sugar out feeds the cell number two
it actually stores sugar in the mainly
in the liver but some on the muscle as
well and some of the kidneys some of the
brain and some in the white blood cell
but mainly in the liver and kidney
that's where the storage happens and the
body stores sugar as something called
glycogen that's the name of it it's
glycogen is a series of glucose
molecules strung together in a chain so
there's two main types of fuel stores in
the body we have the glycogen reserve
and then we have the fat reserve okay
the glycogen reserve which is the sugar
reserve is roughly only 1700 calories
it's very very tiny versus 70,000
calories on a not all beasts average
person so we have 70,000 calories for
fat versus only 1700 that's 1700 for
sugar reserves
okay so insulin helps in the absorption
of fuel in the cell it helps in the
sugar storage which is called glycogen
reserve and number three it converts
excess sugar and carbohydrates into fat
okay so fat comes from the excess
carbohydrates so as soon as the blood
sugars go too high it convert insulin
converts it to fat in the liver so it's
dumping fat into the liver and dumping
fat into the body specifically in the
belly area this is the storage around
the liver and starts spilling off into a
belly a fat belly that's where it's
coming from
so in this section I'm going to talk
about what is excess sugar in the blood
normal blood sugar is between eighty and
a hundred okay milliliters per deciliter
this basically means you have one
teaspoon of sugar per all of your blood
an average person it's roughly one and
one-third gallons of blood that's normal
an average American consumes 31
teaspoons of sugar so you can imagine
how much sugar that is in your body your
insulin needs to deal with it so it has
to get this toxic sugar out protect the
cells and dump it into the reserve which
is your belly so it's converting the
excess sugar to belly fat and that's how
it works okay so the next thing that
happens when you have too much sugar
over a long period of time and too much
sustained insulin we developed something
called insulin resistance where the
receptor that's supposed to receive
insulin becomes blocked okay now what
happens is now the glucose the sugar
can't get into the cell because the key
is not working
to allow the cell to be fed the fuel
that it needs okay so because there's no
signals inside the cell that the glucose
is getting in there there's no feedback
loop to the pancreas to turn it off so
we have an incomplete communication it's
like someone's talking so much but no
one's listening so we have the situation
where no off switch the body compensates
to drive more insulin to try to connect
with this little key to try to drive the
key in there so a person with insulin
resistance has five to seven times more
insulin than a normal person
this is pre-diabetes okay so what
happens is all this excess insulin goes
throughout the body but it doesn't it's
not becoming effective in other words
it's not bringing the sugars down it's
not feeding the cells what it's doing
its going in storage is belly fat so
we're dumping more and more insulin
that's converting this sugar into fat in
the belly and making a fatty liver other
symptoms there's four main big symptoms
with insulin resistance your fatigue
especially after you eat like eat lunch
you want to take a nap number two you
have cravings for sugar and
carbohydrates number three you have
excessive urination at night because
wherever the excess insulin is going
fluid is following it so you're actually
the sometimes you have glucose coming
through the urine you're going to be
peeing more and also even have a lot of
brain fog memory issues you have
inflammation there's a whole list of
symptoms that you can have so there's
several other purposes of insulin that
go beyond just glucose going in the cell
number one protein goes in the cell with
the help of insulin without insulin you
can't absorb protein amino acids in the
cell
that's why diabetics have loss of muscle
collagen muscle weakness they can't
build muscle they have joint issues disk
issues a lot of protein issues and
potassium the major mineral or
electrolyte which is potassium will not
go on the cell as well thereby having
fatigue high sodium that's going to get
high pulse rate high blood pressure
arrhythmias heart is arrhythmias skip
heartbeat palpitations edema swelling in
your feet poor sleep because potassium
helps relax your body muscle cramps
constipation gout kidney stones
okay so insulin is needed for other
things as well so if you wanted a really
good reference book I just came out with
my new book called a new body type guide
it's actually major updates from the
last book that I had which is the 7
principles of fat burning there's more
strategies more effective results it's
easier to implement ok so you're taking
additional strategies of healthy ketosis
in a minute fasting and the body types
all together so it's really about how to
get healthy to the core in long term so
you can do something with
The Hunger without the cravings and be
very very successful
there's 379 pages over a hundred and
fifty-six graphic illustrations so when
I read a book the first thing I look at
it doesn't have any pictures okay if it
doesn't okay
next so I love the visuals full glossary
full index full FAQ full resource is
chapter and I also add it in there's
something called a conscious eating card
you can cut it out in the back so let's
say for example you mess up it tells you
what to do or if you're tempted you can
read this card and it'll probably
discourage you from doing it alright so
I'm doing an introductory special on the
book if you get this book you'll get an
additional bonus okay this is the
companion guide it's a little booklet
called
it's not lose weight to get healthy it's
get healthy to lose the weight very
powerful principle but this book is a
summary of the key points in this book
with special attention to a lot of
pictures on what to eat giving examples
of the meals of what they look like to
have the percentages of fat
carbohydrates and protein so you you can
dive right in read this book probably in
an hour and a half and then fill in all
the details with this book alright I put
a link down below thanks for watching